two stars in a stadium near Moscow world
champion hurdler Sarah geisha penkov and
European triple jump champion Ekaterina
Gordeeva in her last competition before
Rio usually sporting performance is
supposed to be crucial during the last
step in the preparation for the Olympic
Games but today instead of that the
final verdict from Switzerland became a
real male biting affair for the Russian
athletes especially for these two
because you Katarina kunafa and sergei
volkov have both filed lawsuits with the
International Court of Arbitration for
sport
they say it's unfair that all Russian
athletes should be banned because of a
few doping cases every athlete has the
right to take part in the Olympics those
who make the decision are athletes
themselves they know all the preparation
that goes in how can they just simply
romp innocent athletes of one of the
greatest moments of their lives I didn't
think they would do it here at the
Russian Cup meet near Moscow there is
only one topic of conversation reowww
yes or no the athletes here compete with
mixed emotions cautious optimism and the
fear of being barred
there's doping in every country why only
punish us maybe because doping isn't
organized or state-sponsored elsewhere
at least according to reports do you
think that's true you know what I don't
want anything to do with this report the
Russian state is facing accusations that
it not only covered up the doping but
also directed it whenever possible
numerous reports say so but Russian
sports organizations reject the claims
they say the report is politically
motivated you not just as someone who
feels hurt when his land is implicated
but rather more as an expert I just
can't trust this report didi Bullock
the Rio games begin in less than three
weeks do the Russian athletes have any
hope left
who knows if lightning strikes probably
not but if the Sun shines in the day of
the decision and everyone is at a good
mood maybe they will say yes I don't
know if I can still hope anything's
possible if the entire country is banned
from the Olympic Games it would be a
historic and unprecedented decision
you